* Feierliche Musik *
(Pfarrer) Im Namen des Vaters,
des Sohnes und des Heiligen Geistes.
(Alle) Amen.
* Kirchenglocken *
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Hey.
Es wurde nicht
über das Unglück gesprochen.
Merkwürdig:
Man durfte nicht fragen.
Sie müssen sich das vorstellen:
20 Tote.
* Schreie *
Macht auf!
Man musste es zuerst
glauben können.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Was passiert mit uns?
Geht nach Hause und betet.
* Düstere Musik *
* Ruhige Musik *
* Er macht Trompetengeräusche. *
* Blöken *
Ich erinnere mich daran,
als ich ein Junge war:
Auf den Strassen in Escholzmatt
war kein Verkehr.
Im Winter konnte man
über die Strassen schlitteln.
Man musste nicht schauen,
ob ein Auto kommt oder so.
Man schlittelte einfach.
Ich erinnere mich:
Als ich zur Schule ging -
das war Ende der 40er-Jahre -,
spielten wir Jungs
manchmal Fussball auf der Strasse.
Vom Dorfplatz auf die Strasse.
Ein einfaches, gewöhnliches Leben
auf dem Land.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Mann) Nein, benehmt euch, Kinder.
So, nach vorne schauen.
Lächeln, Mund zu.
Ich war immer an allen Orten dabei,
wo es lustig war.
Ja.
Ja, du warst die Ernstere.
Also, die Ruhigere.
- Ja, ja.
Benehmt euch. So, ernst.
Einfach, aber fröhlich waren wir.
Nein, nicht mehr.
Ich war immer dort, wo etwas lief.
Da gab es auch manchmal
ein bisschen eine Sache, oder?
Es war einfach meine Art.
Ja.
Und wir hatten viele Wege.
Wir konnten ...
- Am Bach unten waren wir oft.
Am Bach. In diesem Graben.
Im Sommer waren wir viel am Bach.
Es war eine schöne Jugendzeit.
* Ruhige Musik *
So, die Herren, bereit?
Und ...
Eins, zwei, drei, vier ...
* Ruhige Blasmusik *
Eins, zwei, drei.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein!
Trompeten: Staccato.
Ganz kurz, ganz kurz: # pa-pa.
Gut. Bereit?
Eins, zwei, drei.
Mein Pflegevater,
Gottfried Studer, war Lehrer.
Musikdirektor.
Im Dorf
eine angesehene Persönlichkeit.
Bei der Raiffeisen ganz vorne drin.
Einer, der volksverbunden war
und gut mit den Leuten auskam.
Ein geselliger Kerl.
Ein guter Schütze.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Er führte die Tanzkapelle.
Er war im Dorf
eine gern gesehene Person.
Das wird nichts mehr, die Herren.
Ich habe morgen einen langen Tag.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Herr Direktor, wir haben für
den besonderen Tag etwas vorbereitet.
Aha.
* Hochzeitsmarsch *
Merci vielmals!
Jetzt gehen wir noch was trinken.
* Jubel *
Gut, also.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass er, als er noch ledig war,
nicht viel privat zu Hause war.
Er war ja überall.
An jedem Fest im Dorf
machten sie doch Tanzmusik.
Dass er ein fröhliches,
lustiges Leben führte.
* Melancholische Musik *
Pia, ein Telefon.
Hallo?
* Pia lacht. *
Das Beste ist hier drüben.
Du machst so schöne Dinge.
Hör nicht auf damit,
auch wenn du verheiratet bist
und Kinder hast.
Nein.
- Versprich es mir!
Ja.
Dein alter Mann.
Er hat auf mich gewartet.
Und es hat sich gelohnt.
Geniesst euer Glück - jeden Tag.
Er wird früher gehen.
Ab morgen gehört er mir - für immer.
Für i...
- Für immer.
# Für immer und ewig.
Über die Frau,
die seine Braut wurde ...
... weiss ich eigentlich
nicht viel zu erzählen.
Ich weiss nur, dass sie
aus einer Bähnlerfamilie kam.
Bist du bereit für morgen?
- Ich glaube schon.
Weisst du noch, als wir
das letzte Mal in Luzern waren?
Mhm.
- Das ist schon so lange her.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ich kann euch morgen nicht mitneh-
men, aber diese Runde geht auf mich.
Prost.
- Danke, Herr Direktor.
Machen wir morgen,
wenn Sie aus Luzern zurückkommen,
einen Empfang?
Genau,
wie nach dem Schützenfest 1932.
Das Schützenfest war 1937.
Pia lässt sich nicht wie
ein Schützenkranz nach Hause tragen.
Nach der Schifffahrt
bleiben wir eine Nacht in Luzern.
Das hat sich Pia gewünscht.
Unser Herr Direktor:
Noch nicht einmal verheiratet
und schon ist er nicht mehr der Chef.
Wenigstens hier
bin ich immer noch der Chef.
Euch habe ich noch im Griff.
Genau.
- Zum Wohl.
Zum Wohl. Auf das Leben.
- Prost.
(Radio) Wir in der Schweiz kennen
die Leiden des Totalen Kriegs nicht.
Noch immer sitzen wir,
im fünften Kriegsjahr,
mit unserer Familie am eigenen Tisch
und haben zu essen,
wenn auch Kartoffelbrot ab 1. März
auf unseren Tischen erscheinen wird.
(Mann) Das Entlebuch
war 1944 eine sehr arme Gegend,
eine Region mit vielen Bauern.
Eigentlich keine Wirtschaft.
Man lebte wirklich
von der Landwirtschaft.
1944 machten sich die Leute
natürlich Sorgen wegen des Krieges.
Man hatte Angst,
dass die Schweiz doch noch in
den Krieg involviert werden könnte.
Der Bombenabwurf über Schaffhausen
passierte in diesem Jahr -
mit rund 70 Toten.
Die Schweizer hatten Angst,
man könnte doch noch
in den Krieg involviert werden.
Gleichzeitig
war das reine Überleben,
das eigene Überleben,
auch ein Thema.
Man hatte zu wenig zu essen.
Es gab die Rationierungen.
Man musste wirklich dafür sorgen,
dass man sich und seine Familie
durchbringt.
(Lisbeth) Man hatte Brot-,
Teigwaren- und Fleischmarken.
Es gab Bögen
von der Gemeindekanzlei.
Man musste immer die gleiche Farbe
auf die Bögen kleben.
Es war eine einfache Arbeit, aber
wir wären jeweils lieber rumgerannt.
Aber wir mussten nicht
den ganzen Tag. - Nein.
Man musste alles verdunkeln.
Nachts
hörte man manchmal die Flieger,
die Bomber,
die über die Gegend flogen.
Das war eine seltsame Zeit.
Der Krieg verängstigte einen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Unsere Mutter
war ein ernster Mensch.
Eine liebe Mutter,
aber ein ruhiger Typ.
Überlegte sich alles.
Mami!
Wir waren fünf Kinder.
Die kleinste war erst zweijährig.
Gritli.
- Ja, zweijährig.
Mami!
Lisi, lass deine Schwester in Ruhe!
Es war eine einfache Sache.
Man wuchs damals so auf,
aber wir hatten es schön. - Ja, ja.
Warum
darf ich nicht mit zur Hochzeit?
Onkel Godi hat mich auch eingeladen.
Ich kann doch so gut tanzen.
Hör zu!
Wer in die Kirche will, muss mindes-
tens eine Stunde still sitzen können.
Du hältst es
nicht mal zwei Minuten aus.
# Stägeli uf, Stägeli ab, juhe.
Papi!
Unser Vater war ein Lustiger.
Meine wilde Bohne.
Wenn er morgens in der Käserei
alles wusch,
sang er während der Arbeit immer.
Dann gab es etwas zu lachen.
- Ja.
Ja ...
- Er war ein ganz Lustiger.
Ich komme auch.
- Was? Meine wilde Bohne.
Dann kletterst du auf dem Schiff rum
und fällst ins Wasser.
Und wer rettet dich dann?
- Du.
Nein.
Ich war zur Hochzeit eingeladen,
aber mein Vater erlaubte es nicht.
Er sagte -
weil ich so eine Wilde war -,
ich könnte etwas anstellen
oder ins Wasser fallen
und dann könne er mich nicht retten
und ...
Dann kam die Braut und fand,
er solle sich nicht so anstellen,
er solle das Mädchen doch lassen.
Aber er sagte, das mache er nicht.
Er wolle keine Kinder dabeihaben.
Lisi ...
Pack deine Sachen!
Dafür durfte ich zur Tante.
Echt?
- Ja.
Ins Schächli.
- Das war wieder eine Käserei.
Das war ...
Ich war zufrieden,
aber ich wäre gerne ...
... zur Hochzeit gegangen.
Du bist so schön.
Das passt wie angegossen.
- Ja, es passt schon, aber ...
Ich möchte nicht alleine bleiben.
Du bist doch nicht alleine!
Grossmutter bleibt auch hier.
Heute bist du für einmal die Älteste.
Achte gut auf deine Geschwister,
damit Mama und ich
so richtig tanzen können.
Bereit!
Haarbürste?
Nachthemd?
Also, dann viel Spass!
Und nicht zu wild bei der Tante!
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Du kannst das, versprochen.
Eh, eh, eh!
* Sanfte Musik *
Wann kommst du zurück?
Morgen um diese Zeit
bin ich wieder hier,
als wäre ich nie weg gewesen.
- Versprochen?
Ja.
Die Geschichte des Schiffsunglücks
hat unsere Familie immer begleitet.
Es war immer irgendwo präsent.
Man ging im Herbst in die Kirche
und dachte an die Verstorbenen.
Aber was genau passiert war
und wie es passierte,
darüber sprach man nicht so gerne.
Bei vielen Leuten
weckte das einfach Erinnerungen,
die immer noch schmerzten.
* Kirchenglocken *
* Feierliche Orgelmusik *
Pia Portmann sei
eine sehr begabte Weberin gewesen.
Sie habe wunderschöne Kleider
und Trachten hergestellt.
Eine Tochter, die auch viel
für ihre Familie machte.
Das war in den Kriegszeiten
ja auch wichtig.
Pia Portmann war die wahre,
grosse Liebe meines Grossvaters.
Im Namen des Vaters,
des Sohnes und des Heiligen Geistes.
(Alle) Amen.
Andächtige in Christo dem Herren.
Gottfried und Pia:
Ihr seid mit ernster Absicht
in die Kirche gekommen,
um miteinander
in den Ehestand zu treten.
Ich glaube, wenn mein Grossvater
wirklich mit seiner Pia
hätte zusammenleben können,
wäre das eine sehr harmonische,
glückliche Beziehung gewesen.
Er liebte Pia innig.
(Pfarrer) Dann frage ich euch,
Gottfried und Pia:
Ist es euer treuer
und ungezwungener Wille,
vor Gottes Angesicht ...
... und nach der Form und Vorschrift
der heiligen, katholischen Kirche,
euch rechtmässig
als Ehemann und Ehefrau anzunehmen?
Ja.
* Düstere Orgelmusik *
Pst.
Im Namen des Vaters und des Sohnes
und des Heiligen Geistes, Amen.
* Düstere Orgelmusik *
So tragt eure Ringe als Zeichen,
dass ihr euch liebt und ehrt ...
... und die Treue haltet ...
... bis dass der Tod euch scheidet.
(Beide)
Bis dass der Tod uns scheidet.
In nomine Patris
et Filii et Spiritus Sancti.
Amen.
* Düstere Orgelmusik *
* Kirchenglocken *
Mein Grossvater wollte seiner Frau
und der Hochzeitsgesellschaft
etwas Spezielles bieten.
Er organisierte
eine Hochzeit in Luzern.
In dieser Zeit, 1944,
war es für viele Menschen aus
Escholzmatt sehr aussergewöhnlich,
mal nach Luzern zu gehen.
Das konnte sich
auch nicht jeder leisten.
Mein Grossvater war 45,
sein ganzes Leben ledig.
Er konnte sicher
etwas zur Seite legen.
Und gerade auch noch
auf ein Schiff zu gehen,
war etwas sehr Spezielles,
etwas, das viele Leute bis dahin
noch nie gemacht hatten.
Die Hochzeit
war wirklich ein Ereignis für alle,
die eingeladen waren.
* Melancholische Musik *
Wirklich ein guter Hut. Ganz gut.
Auch zufrieden?
Schon wieder am Rauchen.
War bei dir alles gut? Sehr schön.
Und ihr zwei? Zufrieden mit allem?
- Wunderbar! Vielen Dank!
Schön, seid ihr hier!
- Ein wunderbarer Tag.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Und du? Gut gegessen?
- Ja, sehr lecker.
Voll bis oben.
- Es hätte noch.
Pia strahlt auch.
- Ja, ich auch.
Sie hätte unserer Mutter gefallen.
Pia? Das musst du dir anhören:
eine Todesanzeige.
"In tiefster Trauer machen wir Ihnen
die schmerzliche Mitteilung,
dass es Gott, dem Allmächtigen,
gefallen hat,
heute Vormittag, 10.15 Uhr ..."
- Was?
"... unser liebes, treues
und unvergessliches Mitglied,
Fräulein Pia Portmann ..."
"... Fräulein Pia Portmann
von Wertherheim ..."
"... ins bessere Jenseits der Ehe
abzuberufen."
"Die treu Dahingegangene
erreichte ein Jungfrauenalter
von 27 Jahren und vier Monaten."
Die Todesanzeige in der Hochzeits-
zeitung war ein Auf-den-Arm-nehmen:
Jetzt ist Pia Portmann weg,
vergeben durch die Ehe.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass es eine dunkle Vorahnung war.
Im Nachhinein
eher ein missglückter Scherz.
"Nach kurzem, schwerem Liebesleiden
fiel sie einem verführerischen
Männerherzen zum Opfer."
Ja, das bin ich.
"Sie möge im Ehehimmel
unsere Fürbitterin sein."
Ein schöner Tod.
- Nichts von Tod!
Jetzt fängt das Leben
erst richtig an.
* Ruhige Volksmusik *
Der Schiffsführer,
Rudolf Müller-Kleinmayer,
war auch zum Fest eingeladen.
Er genoss das, war gerne mit dabei.
Er habe auch Wein getrunken -
zwar nicht übermässig viel,
aber doch etwa drei Gläser
beim Mittagessen.
Dann habe es
noch einen Kaffee Schnaps gegeben
und noch einen Imbiss
vor der Abfahrt.
Dort habe er nochmals
zwei Gläser Wein getrunken.
Zwischendrin, als das Fest
so ausgelassen und fröhlich war,
legte sich der Schiffsführer
im Boot hin,
um sich ein wenig zu erholen.
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
Wir könnten auch
so einen Apparat kaufen.
Wofür?
Ja, wenn die Bauern
mit der Milch Verspätung haben.
Die haben ja auch kein Telefon.
Wenn jemand Käse bestellen möchte?
- Dann sollen sie vorbeikommen.
Du könntest wieder
mit Pia im Chor singen
und mich und die Kinder
trotzdem anrufen.
Vielleicht rufen wir zusammen an,
wenn wir wieder mal weggehen -
so wie heute.
Godi, gehen wir mal ins Tessin?
- Oh ja!
Am 1. August nach Ascona,
um das Feuerwerk zu sehen.
Hast du es schon mal gesehen?
- Nein.
Das machen wir.
Godi?
Hast du es wirklich
immer ernst gemeint,
als du in der Kirche Ja sagtest?
- Was meinst du?
"Seid ihr bereit,
die Kinder anzunehmen,
die Gott euch schenken will
und sie im Geist Christi
und seiner Kirche zu erziehen?"
Ja, ich will.
* Sie flüstert. *
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Auf dich
muss man schon ständig aufpassen.
(Frau) Godi! Pia! Das Foto.
In der Hochzeitsgesellschaft waren
v.a. Verwandte der beiden Familien.
Verwandte der Familie Studer,
meines Grossvaters,
und Verwandte von Pia Portmann.
Es waren auch viele von Pias Freun-
dinnen an der Hochzeit mit dabei,
junge Frauen, die mit ihr zusammen
im Alleluja-Chor sangen.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Düstere Musik *
(Mann) Onkel Edi
war schon ein etwas Spezieller.
Man nannte ihn im Dorf "Boden-Edi".
Er war durch das Jassen bekannt.
Ein fanatischer Jasser.
Er war auch durch das Motorradfahren
bekannt.
Er fuhr eine Triumph Tiger
und nicht immer langsam.
Onkel Edi war Besitzer eines Nauens.
Er führte gewerbsmässig
Transporte aus.
Ich glaube, es war so:
Er hätte Bahnschotter
verladen müssen,
aber an dem Tag
waren die Bahnwagen nicht bereit.
Sie mussten das
dann wohl erst gegen 18 Uhr machen.
Er musste also so drei, vier Stunden
da draussen warten.
Da kommt der Amerikaner.
Deutscher Saukerl. Ein harter Hund.
Macht mal vorwärts, verdammt!
Ein Schweizer
hat auf dieser Welt nichts zu melden.
Er war ein Junggeselle.
Er blieb ledig.
Er war dann auch nicht immer
so gut drauf.
Aber jetzt im Nachhinein
ist mir auch bewusst, warum.
Wenn er ein wenig erbost war,
merkte man besser,
dass er ein Glasauge hatte.
Aber wenn er normal,
friedlich dreinschaute,
hätte man nicht gedacht,
dass er ein Glasauge hat.
Probleme hatte er eigentlich nie.
Er musste auch sehr viel
Kompass fahren.
Im Nebel muss man ja immer die Zeit
messen, die Nummern aufschreiben,
Touren aufschreiben ... Das musste
er immer mit einem Auge ablesen.
Das konnte er bestens.
(Mann) Edi, ist gut, wir sind fertig.
Ja, verdammt! Endlich!
Dann kamen die Wagen, sie luden aus
und fuhren
so um 19.30, 19.45 Uhr ab.
Im Oktober
wird es natürlich schon bald dunkel.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass mein Vater und meine Mutter ...
... noch gar nie
auf einem Schiff waren.
Und dass Onkel Gottfried,
der Bräutigam ...
... seine nächste Verwandtschaft
bei so einem Fest ...
... auswärts,
in einem Hotel in Kastanienbaum
am Vierwaldstättersee ...
Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen,
dass sie die Hochzeitsgesellschaft
nicht zeitig aus dem Hotel brachten.
Die Festbrüder dachten doch,
dass sie das Fest
noch so richtig geniessen wollten.
* Fröhliche Musik, Jauchzer *
Um 20.20 Uhr wollte man abfahren,
damit man um 21.09 Uhr in Luzern
den letzten Zug nach Escholzmatt
erwischen konnte.
Leider verspätete man sich aber.
Nicht alle auf einmal!
Wir haben volle Magen.
Das ist nur für Schwimmer.
Den kennst du: Ein Entlebucher
geht ins Schwimmbad ...
Einsteigen bitte,
wir müssen uns beeilen,
um am Bahnhof den Zug zu erwischen.
- Wartet! - Pia, komm!
Ich will nicht schwimmen.
- Willst du ein Teechen?
30, 31 ...
... 31, 32, 33 ...
Das Motorboot "Schwalbe" hatte
eine Ladekapazität von 30 Personen.
Schon auf der Hinfahrt
war das Schiff überladen.
Da waren 38 Personen
auf diesem Motorboot.
Auf der Heimfahrt waren es noch 33,
weil gewisse Leute
sich schon früher verabschiedeten.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Nur wenige Leute,
die damals dabei waren,
erzählten später über das Unglück.
Eine, die das machte,
war die Schwester des Bräutigams.
(Tonbandaufnahme)
Es war der 12. Oktober.
Es war dunkel.
Im Oktober
ist es ja schon früher dunkel.
Aber alles war friedlich,
fröhlich bis am Schluss.
Und wir sangen.
Da konnte ich gut singen.
Heute bin ich zu alt, um zu singen.
Ich bin ja jetzt 93 ...
Nein, 97!
97-jährig.
Mama war im Kirchenchor.
Das machte sie sehr gerne.
Es war eine fröhliche Gesellschaft
in dieser Zeit.
Und ... äh ...
Bei den Leuten war sie ...
Das war noch ganz süss:
Sie war für alle Frau Senn-Schnyder.
Das konnte ich nicht vergessen.
Es kamen sehr harte Jahre.
Aber jetzt
kann ich gut darüber sprechen.
Vorher konnte ich das nicht.
Das war hart.
Sie konnte nicht mehr schlafen.
Ab da musste sie
immer Schlaftabletten nehmen -
bis zu ihrem letzten Tag.
Sie starb im 100. Lebensjahr.
Ich glaube,
das war extrem hart für sie.
* Fröhliche Musik *
* Gottfried
trällert die Melodie mit. *
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Murer Edi war natürlich
eine Kapazität eines Schiffsführers.
Er kannte Wind, Wetter und See.
In allen Belangen.
Wehe, man hatte abends die Lichter
nicht rechtzeitig installiert!
V.a. in den Herbst-
und Frühlingsmonaten,
in denen es früher dunkel wird
und morgens länger Nacht ist.
Die Lichter waren immer montiert.
Es hiess nie: "Es beginnt zu tagen,
wir können trotzdem abfahren."
Die Regel war:
"So geht es und nicht anders."
Er war kein Risikomensch.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
* Fröhliche Musik *
Rosa, ich kann nicht schlafen.
(Frau) Lisi, geh jetzt ins Bett!
Ja, ja, ich gehe gleich.
* Düstere Musik *
Geh jetzt schlafen!
* Fröhliche Musik *
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
# Schutzengel mein ...
# ... lass mich dir empfohlen sein.
# Tag und Nacht, ich bitte dich ...
# ... beschütz',
regier' und leite mich.
# Lass mich leben,
recht und fromm ...
# ... dass ich zu dir
in den Himmel komm.
* Knall *
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Was war das?
- Ganz ruhig!
Die "Schwalbe"
mit der Hochzeitsgesellschaft
war Richtung Luzern unterwegs.
Und von Luzern her
kam der Nauen "Schwalmis" entgegen.
Offenbar sah der Schiffsführer
diesen Nauen sehr spät.
Und als er sie sah,
reagierte er falsch.
Er steuerte das Boot in die falsche
Richtung - direkt in den Nauen.
* Dramatische Musik *
Hey!
Ganz ruhig! Nur ruhig bleiben!
Ist dir etwas passiert?
- Ich habe mich erschrocken.
Oh nein, was ist das?
Wir müssen hier raus.
Hilfe!
Da sagte der Bootsführer:
"Nur ruhig sitzen bleiben!"
Das rief er.
"Nur alle ruhig bleiben!"
"Das Schiff geht nicht unter."
Und ich war die Letzte ...
... die noch rausging.
Und ich sagte noch: "Kommt auch!"
Das Motorboot, die "Schwalbe",
war ein sehr tiefes Boot.
Und der hohe
und auch sehr schwere Nauen
hat das Boot
praktisch unter Wasser gedrückt.
Nach dem Zusammenstoss
ging es nur ein paar Sekunden,
bis Wasser im Boot war,
und etwa 30 Sekunden,
bis das Boot unterging.
Du musst dir vorstellen,
dass Wasser in einen Kessel läuft,
ziemlich schnell, und er kippt um.
So schnell sei das gegangen.
Sehr viele dieser Leute
waren in einer Todesfalle.
Sie waren in der Kabine des Schiffs,
wo die Türen sehr schnell
vom Wasser zugedrückt wurden.
Sie hatten keine Chance,
aus dieser Schiffskabine zu kommen.
Macht auf!
* Verzweifelte Schreie *
* Dramatische Musik *
* Schreie von draussen *
Ich kam nach oben und wusste,
was man machen musste:
ein Hohlkreuz
und die Füsse zusammenpressen.
Aber ich hielt nicht lange durch.
Sie habe das
in der "Stadt Gottes" gelesen.
Das war damals
eine katholische Zeitschrift,
die am Sonntag kam.
Und dort drin habe gestanden -
etwa einen Monat vorher oder so -,
dass man, wenn man die Arme
schön gerade ausstrecke
und ein Hohlkreuz mache
und gerade nach oben schaue,
nicht untergehe.
Und das habe sie gemacht.
Wie es dem Brautpaar
bei diesem Unfall erging,
ist eine der Geschichten,
die immer sehr unterschiedlich
erzählt wurde.
Das war auch etwas,
das mich sehr interessierte.
Dem ging ich nach.
* Pia schreit. *
Pia! Pia!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Pia!
Godi!
Mein Grossvater
sprach selber überhaupt nicht gerne
bzw. praktisch nie darüber,
wie dieser Moment war.
Als es das Schiff hob - vorne waren
meine Eltern innen drin, unten ...
Und er konnte gerade hinüber
auf den Nauen.
* Dramatische Musik *
Pia, gib mir deine Hand!
Pia!
* Schreie *
(Edi) Da nimm, verdammt!
* Dramatische Musik *
Pia!
Godi!
Ich komme nicht rauf.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Diese Todesangst.
Ich weiss nur, dass sie nachher
gar nichts mehr wusste -
was auf dem Schiff war,
also, auf dem Nauen.
Ab dem Zeitpunkt,
als sie dort oben war,
war sie fast immer wie weggetreten.
Und am Morgen
erwachte sie zu Hause im Bett.
Unser Nachbar da vorne,
Schnyder Sepp vom Schwandacher ...
Er war Klarinettist -
in der Tanzkapelle auf dem Schiff.
Und ich fragte ihn natürlich:
"Wie ging das dort zu und her?"
Der mit der Handorgel
öffnete die Handorgel
und sprang ins Wasser.
Sie gingen nicht unter.
Sie hatten etwas wie Schwimmhilfen.
Er sagte mir:
"Die Klarinette fand ich nie mehr."
Die ging unter.
Gib mir deine Hand, Pia!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Godi, ich kann nicht mehr.
Noch einmal! Probier!
Godi!
Pia!
* Dramatische Musik *
(Sämi) Am Tag nach dem Unglück
stand das Dorf Escholzmatt,
die ganze Bevölkerung,
unter richtigem Schock.
(Rosa) Das war so eine Stimmung ...
Sie begannen, anzurufen.
Wir hatten neu gerade ein Telefon.
Das wurde wahrscheinlich
überbeansprucht.
Aber es kam morgens um 7 Uhr
in den Nachrichten.
Meine Tante frühstückte ...
... in Luzern und hörte das.
Und da wollte sie anrufen.
Sie rief bei der Post an
und die Frau Posthalterin
wusste natürlich auch schon,
was da passiert war.
So erfuhren es dann die Verwandten.
Gestandene Männer
hätten auf der Strasse geweint.
Etwas, das man sich in dieser Zeit
fast nicht vorstellen konnte:
dass richtige Bauern
auf offener Strasse weinten.
Es traf natürlich auch die Familien,
die Kinder,
die auf die Rückkehr ihrer Eltern
warteten.
Aber die Eltern
kamen einfach nicht mehr nach Hause.
* Unverständliche Gespräche
von unten *
(Rosa)
Unsere Grossmutter war ja bei uns.
Und dann waren zwei Nachbarsfrauen
bei Grossmutter im Wohnzimmer.
Und sie sagten:
"Sie sind ertrunken."
(Frau) Untergegangen.
Das ganze Schiff ist untergegangen.
Sie kämen nicht mehr nach Hause.
- Auch Kurt ist gestorben.
Sie kommen nie mehr nach Hause.
Das ist eine Katastrophe.
* Traurige Musik *
Das war einfach ...
... wie ein Traum.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob das stimmt, was sie erzählten.
Oder war das gar nicht wahr?
Unsere Grossmutter
war dann so eine starke Frau.
Das hörte ich
und habe es nicht vergessen.
Sie sagte:
"Ich habe in meinem Leben
so viel durchgemacht,
ich werde auch die Kraft haben,
das zu tragen."
Sie konnte das.
Ich war im Schächli
und hatte dort geschlafen.
Sie hatten ein Ofenloch
und ich hörte, dass sie unten ...
Ich erwachte davon.
Ich hörte, dass meine Tante sagte:
"Wir sagen Lisi noch nichts,
sonst will sie nach Hause."
* Traurige Musik *
Und als ich nach Hause kam ...
... war das
natürlich gar nicht mehr dasselbe.
Als ich ging, waren alle noch da.
Und als ich zurückkam ...
... war das ...
Ja ...
Wie soll ich das beschreiben?
Als Kind so ein beklemmendes ...
... eigentlich ein komisches Gefühl,
aber ...
Zuerst musste man es glauben können.
So war es.
- Nicht wahr?
Es war irgendwie wie ein Traum.
Dann überlegte man sich ...
- Zwischen wahr und Traum.
Wie eine Geschichte:
"Das ist gar nicht wahr."
Und dann musste man sagen:
"Es ist doch wahr."
Ja, es ist doch wahr.
Rosa!
Hör auf!
Hör auf! Rosa, hör auf!
Ich bin da.
Als ich aufwachte,
war meine Mama noch im Bett.
Ich glaube,
sie hat gar nicht geschlafen.
Gegen 3 Uhr morgens
brachte die Polizei ...
... sie nacheinander
nach Escholzmatt.
Dann assen wir zu Mittag.
Vor dem Mittagessen ging sie
mit der Köchin in den Estrich,
um unseren Kinderwagen zu holen.
Meine Mama sagte: "Ich muss doch
das kleine Kind holen."
Das Jüngste im Schürli
war nicht ganz jährig -
zehn Monate alt.
Sie hatte die ganze Nacht
darüber nachgedacht,
dass da ja noch niemand gekommen sei
und niemand helfe usw.
Sie ging mit dem leeren Kinderwagen
ins Schürli
und rund eineinhalb Stunden später
kam sie mit Anni zurück.
Sie blieb dann bei uns.
(Hermann) Hier im Schürli -
gerade in den ersten paar Tagen -
sahen alle irgendwie so traurig aus.
Sie hatten schwarzes Zeugs an.
Und was mir deutlich geblieben ist:
"Jö, die armen Jungs da."
"Jö, die armen Kinder da."
Das ist mir geblieben.
Und merkwürdig:
Alle weinten.
Sie wischten sich ständig
die Tränen ab.
Sie hatten dauernd
ein Taschentuch vor dem Gesicht.
Das ist mir schon geblieben.
Es gab auch keine Musik mehr
im Haus.
Vorher hat doch jeden Tag
irgendjemand
Trompete oder Handorgel gespielt
oder unsere Mutter
hat mit uns gesungen.
Null. Keine Musik mehr.
Gottfried sagte mehrmals:
"Wenn ich dieses Fest
nicht organisiert hätte,
wäre das alles nicht passiert."
"Ich bin schuld.
Ich bin der Ursprung."
Das machte ihm stark zu schaffen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ich muss ehrlich sagen: Onkel Edi
hat praktisch nie davon erzählt.
Sie müssen sich das vorstellen:
20 Tote.
Und er war beteiligt.
Er war gefahren.
Das setzte ihm wahrscheinlich
schon etwas zu.
Die Geretteten wurden ja dann auf
die Hauptwache in Luzern überführt.
Dort wurden sie befragt.
Und sie müssen alle
ähnliche Dinge gesagt haben.
Er regte sich enorm darüber auf.
Er sagte,
das und das habe nicht gestimmt
und sie hätten
einfach etwas gesagt usw.
Am nächsten Tag war die Polizei da.
Wie bei einer - wie sagt man? -
bei einer Unfallaufnahme.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Murer?
Ja?
Gehört der Nauen Ihnen?
- Ja, sicher.
Waren Sie beim Unglück
auch am Steuer?
Mhm.
Ich muss Sie zum Unfall befragen.
So?
- Wie lief der Unfall ab?
Tja ...
Er schwenkte einfach ein.
In Richtung Ufer. Also, zu mir hin.
War der Nauen beleuchtet?
Ich hatte die Positionslampen
30, vielleicht 40 cm ...
... vom Schiffsrand
am Bug angebracht.
Der Nauen war mit Sicherheit
sehr gut sichtbar.
Man sagte ja sogar, er sei in Luzern
ohne Licht abgefahren.
Das war ja verrückt.
Die Leute einer Dampfschiff-
gesellschaft haben das behauptet.
Da muss ich sagen,
wurde er extrem wütend,
als das ausgesagt wurde.
Er fuhr wirklich mit Licht ab.
Das Licht war für ihn immer wichtig.
Und es ist auch wichtig.
Hören Sie zu:
Ich habe das Motorboot
von Weitem gesehen.
Und Sie dachten nicht daran,
dass Sie zusammenstossen?
Bei einer normalen Weiterfahrt
hätte ein Abstand
von 30, vielleicht 40 m bestanden.
Und dann schwenkt der Saukerl
einfach ein.
Und dann sank es?
Ja.
Und was machten Sie?
Das Getriebe sofort gestoppt.
Ich eilte zum Kiel.
Ich wollte natürlich helfen.
Was ist mit Ihrem Auge?
Ich habe ein künstliches Auge -
seit 1935.
Als Folge eines Überfalls.
Das war eine leidige Sache
mit diesem Auge.
Murer Edi hatte einen Stiefbruder,
aus der ersten Ehe der Mutter.
Er war ab und zu
etwas zu lange im Dorf.
Da sagte seine Mutter:
"Geh und schau, wo Sepp ist!"
"Er ist nicht nach Hause gekommen.
Geh und schau, wo er ist!"
Also geht er ins Dorf
und dort steht einer.
Er kommt hinauf und hat plötzlich
ein Messer im Auge.
Jetzt war das so:
Jener Person
wurde das Fahrrad gestohlen.
Und diese Person sagte: "Der kommt
damit wieder zurück. Ich warte."
Das war ein ganz blöder Unfall ...
... den er mit 28 erlitt.
Er hat das Auge natürlich verloren.
Das war hin.
Das war etwas ...
Also, ein noch dümmerer Zufall ...
Man kann nicht sagen,
was da passiert wäre.
Und das andere Auge?
Es scheint mir etwas gerötet.
* Düstere Musik *
Steinbruch.
Staub im Auge.
Anfang September.
Ich begab mich in Behandlung
bei Herrn Dr. Strebl.
Ich konnte sechs Tage nicht arbeiten.
Jetzt bin ich
wieder voll arbeitsfähig.
Distanzen schätzen mit einem Auge?
Geht das?
Hören Sie zu:
Ich war gestern Vormittag
zur Kontrolle bei Dr. Strebl.
Es ist wieder alles in Ordnung.
Keinerlei Beeinträchtigungen mehr.
Schreiben Sie auf:
Dr. Strebl. Augenarzt. Luzern.
Er kann Ihnen das bestätigen.
* Düstere Musik *
Sie stellten das Ganze
dann etwas infrage.
Er musste eine Kontrolle machen.
Und sie sagten dann, er sähe so gut,
wie manch einer
mit zwei Augen nicht.
Daher war das kein Hindernis.
* Melancholische Musik *
(Sämi) Schon am Tag nach dem Unglück
wurde das Ganze nachgestellt.
Auch da musste der Nauenführer,
Eduard Murer,
mit seinem Nauen wieder dabei sein.
Es wurde genau nachgestellt,
wie das Unglück passierte.
Sie nahmen ein anderes Schiff.
Sie mussten
genau dieselben Positionen fahren.
Das Schiff
musste genau den Winkel einnehmen,
mit dem es
mit dem Nauen kollidierte.
Es wurde auch bald untersucht,
ob der Nauen denn überhaupt
richtig beleuchtet war.
Das war dann die grosse Frage.
Die Positionslichter
waren normgerecht.
Am Bug ist ein Licht.
Das ist ein weisses, ein helles -
eine normale Glühbirne.
Dann ist am Heck ein Licht.
Das ist meistens hinter der Kabine.
Steuerbord hat Grün,
Backbord hat Rot.
Genau auf den parallelen Linien,
links und rechts,
hatte er sie positioniert.
In der medialen Berichterstattung
nach dem Unglück
wurde Eduard Murer vorverurteilt.
In der "NZZ" z.B. stand,
die Unfallursache sei geklärt.
Es sei klar,
dass der Nauenführer schuld war.
Er sei durch eine schöne Jacht,
die irgendwo angelegt hatte,
abgelenkt gewesen.
Er habe darauf geschaut,
anstatt auf den See.
Das dementierte die
Untersuchungsbehörde aber vehement:
Sie seien noch nicht so weit mit
der Untersuchung, das stimme nicht.
Ich sage jetzt, dass der Bootsführer
schuld war, denn ...
Man sieht viele Stadtlichter
und dazwischen
kam der Nauen entgegen.
Hinten wurde Musik gespielt
und gejohlt.
Und der Schiffsführer ...
Man muss auch wissen,
was die Wirtin ausgesagt hat:
Er habe auch mitgetrunken.
Vor dem Essen.
Und er hat nach dem Essen getrunken.
Und er trank leider
nicht nur Mineralwasser.
Er war sicher nicht voll betrunken,
aber ich sage mal,
er muss angetrunken gewesen sein.
Und ich kann Ihnen sagen,
das weiss ich selber:
Ich machte auch schon Nachtfahrten.
Da muss man extrem schauen.
Die Distanzen und überhaupt -
das ist in der Nacht ganz anders.
Gut, heute hat man ja Radar.
Aber ohne Radar ...
... muss man volle Konzentration
haben.
Wenn Sie nach Luzern fahren
und viele Lichter sehen,
muss man das wirklich
im Auge behalten,
was das rote bzw. grüne Licht macht.
Dann sieht man, wie der Nauen kommt.
Da fehlte es halt schon
an der Konzentration.
Die grosse Frage
bei der Untersuchung war auch,
warum der Schiffsführer
den Fehlentscheid traf.
Warum hat er das Motorboot so
ruckartig auf den Nauen zugesteuert?
Man untersuchte dann, ob er
ein medizinisches Problem hatte -
einen Herzinfarkt oder so.
Das war nicht der Fall.
Er ertrank.
Man stellte aber fest, dass er
nicht wenig Alkohol im Blut hatte.
Und das war sicher mit ein Grund
für das Fehlverhalten,
dass er sich
so falsch entschieden hatte.
(Radio) In der Luzerner Bucht
des Vierwaldstättersees
hat sich gestern Abend
eine schwere Katastrophe ereignet.
Eine Hochzeitsgesellschaft
aus Escholzmatt
hatte bei St. Niklausen die Ver-
mählung eines jungen Paares gefeiert.
Bei Dunkelheit
fuhren 33 Personen der Gesellschaft
mit einem gemieteten Motorboot
nach Luzern zurück.
Als sie in der Nähe des Haslihorns
vorbeifuhren,
stiess das Boot
mit einem Nauen zusammen.
Das Motorboot kenterte und
die ganze Mannschaft fiel ins Wasser.
Insgesamt sind 20 Personen ertrunken.
Unter den Verunglückten
befindet sich die Braut.
Im Dorf Escholzmatt
wurden 14 Kinder zu Vollwaisen.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
(Pfarrer) Gottfried Portmann.
Agatha Portmann-Jenny.
Pia Studer-Portmann.
Alfred Portmann.
Margrith Koch.
Hermann Studer-Kaufmann.
Lisi Studer-Kaufmann.
Da hörte ich, wie der Pfarrer
die Leute verkündete.
Und da wusste ich:
Die sind gestorben.
Toni Kaufmann-Studer.
Rosa Kaufmann-Studer.
Gertrud Bieri.
Josef Studer.
Franz-Sepp Studer-Kaufmann.
Anna Studer-Kaufmann.
Toni Studer.
Mareili Studer.
Für die Kinder
war die Todesnachricht
natürlich ein riesiger Schock.
Auch das war im "Entlebucher
Anzeiger" dann beschrieben,
wie ein Kind danach immer wieder
nach seiner Mutter rief
und einfach sagte:
"Mami, bitte komm nach Hause!"
Rudolf Müller-Kleinmayer.
Katharina Emmenegger-Studer.
Peter Achermann.
Katharina Studer-Muther.
Marie Theresia Studer.
* Dramatische Musik *
Sie fanden die Toten
dann sukzessive.
Etwa einen Tag später ...
... brachten sie sie dann
mit so einem Militärkonvoi.
Das habe ich mir angesehen.
* Traurige Musik *
Auf einer Seite die Braut.
Sie hatte wieder
das weisse Kleid an.
Ihre Eltern und Geschwister,
die ertrunken waren.
Und auf der anderen Seite
das kleine Mareili,
das Mädchen aus der zweiten Klasse.
Dann dessen Eltern.
Und dann die Eltern
von denen von der Güntere
und vom Blutmoos.
Immer schön Mann und Frau.
* Traurige Musik *
Wollt ihr mit mir kommen?
(Lisbeth) Als wir dann
die Leichen beschauen konnten ...
Das löschte bei mir das lebendige
Bild der Eltern komplett aus.
Ich wusste genau,
was sie erzählt und gemacht hatten,
aber ich konnte sie nicht
zurückholen.
Ich sah immer die Särge.
Ja ...
- Ja, das sind so riesige Eindrücke.
Das hat in mir ... Das ist fast ...
Ich muss sagen:
Dieser Moment war wie eingebrannt.
Ja, das ist ...
Sie haben einfach ...
Man sah sieh
und man erkannte sie auch noch.
Ja.
Aber wir hatten trotzdem
einen Schockzustand.
Das ist ganz klar.
- So viele Särge in einer Reihe ...
Ich weiss noch genau, wo sie waren.
- Ja, ich auch.
Wir konnten sie ja berühren.
- Ja, ja.
Ja, das sind ...
Das sind dumme Momente.
Für Kinder sowieso.
* Traurige Musik *
Ich war ganz brav.
Was passiert mit uns?
Wir wussten ja nicht,
was kommen würde.
Diese Angst blieb mir einfach.
Und ob wir
in der Güntere bleiben können.
Dann hörte man ja, dass sie uns
verteilen wollten. - Ja.
Wir hätten einander verloren.
Wir wollen zusammenbleiben.
Wir wollen nicht zu anderen Eltern.
Ihr müsst jetzt stark sein.
Geht nach Hause und betet.
Wir hatten einen jungen Knecht.
Ich sagte ihm, wenn die kommen ...
... solle er uns
im Heizungskeller einschliessen
und den Schlüssel mitnehmen.
Wir würden still sein
und sie würden uns nicht finden.
Zum Glück versprach er uns das.
Ich war sicher, er würde es machen.
Es kamen viele Anfragen
von weit her -
schweizweit
und auch aus dem Ausland.
Sie sagten:
"Ja, wir könnten so ein Waisenkind
auch noch brauchen."
"Wir könnten auch noch eins nehmen."
Ich kann mich daran erinnern,
dass sie sich das jüngste ansahen.
Es wäre zu einer Lehrerfamilie
nach Hasle gekommen.
Die hatten keine Kinder.
Das weiss ich noch.
Und davor
hatte ich eine riesige Angst.
Das war das Schrecklichste
nach allem anderen:
als wir hörten,
dass sie uns verteilen wollen.
* Melancholische Musik *
Die Trauerfeier am 17. Oktober 1944
war wohl die grösste,
die es in Escholzmatt bzw.
im ganzen Entlebuch je gegeben hat.
Die Zeitungen schrieben
von 2'000 bis 3'000 Trauergästen.
Bundesrat Philipp Etter
war an der Trauerfeier anwesend,
praktisch
die ganze Luzerner Regierung,
viele politische Behörden,
70 Geistliche,
darunter
Bischof Franziskus von Streng.
Es war eine unglaubliche Trauerfeier
an diesem düsteren Tag.
* Dramatische Musik *
Wir haben enorm geweint.
Ja, das war nicht lustig.
Und die vielen Leute immer ...
- Ja.
Daran kann ich mich
ganz gut erinnern.
Und es regnete wie aus Kübeln.
- Ja.
* Dramatische Musik *
Es konnten
einfach diejenigen ans Grab,
von denen gerade jemand
beerdigt wurde.
Es war alles eingeteilt.
- Ja, weil es so viele waren.
* Dramatische Musik *
* Düstere Musik *
(Hermann) Die Zeitungen
in der Talschaft versuchten,
das Unglück zu beschreiben:
"Die grosse Ernte".
(Sämi) Mit dem Titel
"Die grosse Ernte Gottes"
war natürlich gemeint: Gott verfügt.
Darüber sprach man dann schon.
Wie man das verarbeiten muss.
Und zwar hiess es einfach:
"Das war jetzt Gottes Wille."
"Und das muss man annehmen."
So verarbeitete man das Unglück.
Man dachte:
"Es muss irgendeinen Sinn haben,
dass Gott uns das antut."
"Irgendeinen Zweck sieht er darin.
Er will uns prüfen."
Oder: "Er will uns vor eine
schwierige Herausforderung stellen."
Dein Wille geschehe ...
... wie im Himmel, so auf Erden.
Also hat es keinen Sinn ...
... da Schuldige zu suchen.
Also ...
Was ja heute sehr üblich ist:
Man sucht Sündenböcke.
Wir haben gelernt,
dass man das nicht machen soll.
Schlussendlich befand das Gericht,
dass Eduard Murer nicht schuld war.
Er wurde von allen Punkten
freigesprochen.
Es wurde ihm nichts zur Last gelegt.
Das Dumme ist einfach,
dass es passiert ist, oder?
Und warum? Das wissen die Götter.
Das Unglück war schlussendlich
eine Verkettung von
mehreren unglücklichen Umständen:
Zum einen hatte der Schiffsführer
sicher einen gewissen Zeitdruck.
Er musste die Gesellschaft
rechtzeitig nach Luzern bringen.
Zum anderen war er alkoholisiert.
Das Schiff war überladen.
Auch das hatte natürlich
einen gewissen Einfluss
auf die Anzahl der Verstorbenen.
Das Gericht sagte am Schluss klar,
dass die alleinige Schuld
beim verstorbenen Schiffsführer
Rudolf Müller-Kleinmayer lag.
Daran dachte ich bis heute noch nie,
jemandem die Schuld zu geben.
Die wollten das ja alle nicht.
"Eure Eltern sind jetzt im Himmel."
"Sie schauen von oben
herab zu euch."
"Aber sie können sich nicht
um euch kümmern."
"Ihr müsst mir glauben:
Wenn ich etwas ändern könnte,
würde ich alles anders machen."
"Ich kann eure Eltern
nicht ersetzen."
"Ihr müsst jetzt stark sein."
(Beide) "Haltet zusammen,
seid füreinander da."
"Ihr müsst nicht fort."
* Melancholische Musik *
Unser Onkel und unsere Tante
kamen zu uns in die Käserei Güntere.
Dann konnten wir alle
zusammenbleiben:
Grossmutter, wir fünf Kinder,
Sepp und Käthi.
Ja.
Es ging irgendwie gut weiter.
- Ja, es ging gut weiter.
Das muss ich immer sagen.
Dafür, dass sie so ...
Das haben wir oft zueinander gesagt:
Fünf Kinder von einem Tag
auf den anderen annehmen ...
Fünf Kinder!
Und wir waren lebendige.
- Ja, ja.
Keine Blockkinder, die so ...
Da lief jeweils was.
Daran änderte sich nicht viel.
- Nein.
Erinnerst du dich
an das alte Fahrrad?
Wir machten also auch Sachen,
die ...
Sie mussten mit uns
schon ab und zu schimpfen. - Ja.
* Geheimnisvolle Musik *
(Hermann) Nach dem Unglück nahm
unser Pflegevater, Gottfried ...
... uns Jungs vom Schürli zu sich -
in die Wohnung, die er mit
seiner Braut Pia vorbereitet hatte.
Im Dorf waren wir etwas eingesperrt.
Wir durften nicht raus.
Es sei zu gefährlich draussen.
Das war eine etwas trübe Zeit.
Über das Unglück
wurde nicht gesprochen.
Alles über das Unglück, meine Eltern
und unsere Familiengeschichte
vernahm ich auswärts.
Zu Hause beim Pflegevater
sprach man nicht über das Unglück.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass es ihn schmerzte,
über so etwas zu sprechen.
Hey, zuerst beten.
Von deiner Gnade, Herr, leben wir.
Und alles, was wir haben,
kommt von dir.
Darum sagen wir dir Dank und Preis.
Tritt segnend ein in unseren Kreis.
Und immer am Schluss des Gebets:
* Er schluchzt. *
"Für die Verstorbenen."
"Für die armen Seelen."
Immer ...
... war das am Schluss des Gebets.
Für die Verstorbenen.
Für die armen Seelen.
Amen.
Guten Appetit.
* Melancholische Musik *
So.
Guten Appetit.
* Melancholische Musik *
Schmeckt es?
- Mhm.
Ich bin halt nicht der beste Koch.
Ich betete dann nachts immer,
dass ich Mutter
unbedingt noch einmal sehen kann.
Immer.
Und ich sah sie dann.
Ich passe auf euch auf.
Du musst keine Angst haben.
Das war so eine Freude.
Ich sah hin,
bis sie nicht mehr da war.
So einen Traum wünschte ich mir.
Und ich träumte es.
Ich habe keine persönliche
Erinnerung an meine Eltern,
die mir wirklich geblieben ist.
Ich sehe mir ab und zu Fotos an ...
... und freue mich,
dass ich solch schöne ...
Es muss angenehm gewesen sein
mit ihnen.
Es müssen im Grossen und Ganzen
friedliche Leute gewesen sein,
was man so hörte.
Was liest du?
Es heisst "Aus Nah und Fern"
von Johanna Spyri.
Es ist eine Geschichte
über Nähe und Ferne.
Ich erzähle sie dir dann mal,
wenn du älter bist.
1946 fand mein Pflegevater eine
Frau, die er im Stillen heiratete.
Und so wurden wir dann
eine richtige Familie.
Es blieb dann nicht dabei,
dass wir im Dorf waren.
Gottfried
kaufte ein kleines Zuhause.
Das machte er eigentlich wegen uns.
Ich bin fest davon überzeugt ...
... dass er das Bauerngut
für uns gekauft hatte.
Dort waren wir fast wieder so
wie damals auf Vaters Gut:
rundherum Land ...
... zwei Kühe, ein Rind,
ein paar Schweinchen ...
... Gänse, Hühner, Katzen.
Einfach alles,
was man auf einem Bauernhof erlebt,
durften wir dort erleben.
Aber er hatte grosse Mühe.
Er zog sich immer mehr zurück.
Er war öfters alleine.
Er machte keine Tanzmusik mehr.
Er blieb aber bis zu seinem Tod
im Musikverein.
Aber er hat ab und zu
schon sehr stark darunter gelitten.
* Düstere Musik *
(Rosa) Im Herbst merkte man das.
- Ja.
Dann war er so ernst.
Und man konnte halt nichts ändern.
- Nein.
Er selber hat ja eigentlich
alles verloren.
Ich dachte später noch öfters:
Dass er danach nicht ...
Peng.
Mit so einer verrückten Sache.
Ja.
Wie er das bewältigt hat ...
Offenbar halfen ihm auch alle.
- Das nehme ich an.
Aber gelitten hat er.
Das hat man ...
- Ja, ja. Ja, ja.
* Melancholische Blasmusik:
"Nearer, My God, to Thee" *
(Dass ihr einander liebt und ehrt,
bis dass der Tod euch scheidet.)
* Melancholische Blasmusik:
"Nearer, My God, to Thee" *
Pia!
Ich ...
... war dabei, als er verunglückte.
Er sagte mir auf dem Dorfplatz:
"Geh ins Probelokal!"
"Bring mein Dirigentenpult rauf!"
Und er ging vom Auto weg
über die Strasse ...
... und verunglückte.
Ich war bei ihm ...
... als er auf der Strasse starb.
Aber ich erinnere mich gerne
an all das,
was sie mir mit auf den Weg gaben:
Freude haben,
wenn man Freude haben darf.
Nachdenklich und vielleicht
auch ein wenig traurig sein,
wenn einem alles wieder hochkommt.
Aber immer in der Zuversicht,
dass das halt
ein anderer Wille war -
vom Herrgott -, dass es so kam.
* Beschwingte Büchel-Klänge *
Wir hielten schon zusammen.
- Ja, ja.
Wir stritten uns zwar,
hatten es dann aber wieder lustig.
Das ist so.
- Doch, doch. Doch, doch.
Das ist normal, wenn du so etwas ...
Oder überhaupt bei Kindern.
- Ja.
Die halten zusammen.
Die sind beieinander.
Ja, wir hatten zusammen
schon viele schöne Stunden.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Fröhliches Kinderlachen *
puretype gmbh / UT-Redaktion Zug
Im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2020